The third reason the code might not have been covered is that the test suite might simply
just be inadequate, and if the test suite is inadequate, we have to decide what to do about it.
So one option of course is to improve the test suites so that the code gets covered.
The other option is not to worry about it, and of course, since it should in good coverage
could be difficult, it can easily be the case that we'll just decide to ship our software
without achieving a 100% code coverage, and there is nothing in here to be wrong with that
because coverage testing, like all forms of testing, is basically just a cost-benefit tradeoff.
The question we have to ask is are we getting enough value out of
doing the testing to offset the cost of doing the testing.
And so if we do ships software with uncovered code, we basically have to do
is admit to ourselves that we're perfectly okay with the fact that the customers who are on
the receiving end of the software might be the first people who will actually run it.